[Music]
we're headed out to horse Island
the Peabody has been in possession of
this island since the early 1970s
we're currently building a teaching
Pavilion in partnership with the
architecture school
[Music]
he said well how about if you guys could
build a lab building for us a new
building that would be off the grid
this is the first project of the new
regenerative building Lab at the Yale
School of Architecture which is a sort
of advanced version of the Yale building
project
[Music]
it was sort of a crazy time to graduate
so it worked out really well to have
this unique but temporary project to
work on the seminar started as the
regenerative building seminar in as a
spring course last semester turned into
a design phase and then ultimately now
into the construction phase of the ELP
body Coastal Research Center
the idea of this building is to provide
a sort of hub for researchers who are
visiting doing work for classes coming
to study parts of the island but of
course it's also a bit of a balancing
act right because this is a Preserve in
a way and we want to preserve it because
otherwise the research that you can do
it here is not going to be that exciting
if we've damaged the ecosystem too much
design for disassembly is the idea of
using screws and fasteners which you
could remove so theoretically you could
take this building apart the same way
that you put it together and because we
prefabricated so much of the building on
West Campus how we were going to make
those components and then disassemble
them and package them to be able to
rebuild them really efficiently here
where we're lacking a lot of our tools
and equipment
so when the building is ultimately
disassembled we can reuse all of the
materials again I'm pretty confident
that we'll have it ready for use in late
spring
every day is is a fun New problem to
solve and a lot of variety a lot of
different things certainly beats the
monotony of sitting at a computer all
day long so it's it's really fun as one
of the guys on the crew says this is the
best day of my life and he says it every
day so I think that's a good sign
[Music]